if someone in the early 20s was was
saying to you that you know richard
you've had a very successful illustrious
career looking at your accolades you're
one of the one 100 people in britain
that makes britain a good place to live
a legend allegedly yeah the other 99 are
but boy they're terrible
what would you say is this balance
between
do what you find interesting do what you
like kind of vibes versus but i need to
make money to make ends meet well that's
the thing i think know your passion
and so the little test i always have is
you're on a desert island are you
allowed four or five books but they're
only about one topic what's the topic
and people go oh is that well that's
your passion probably
now
find a way of making enough money
to to get by with that topic and you
probably got the recipe for happiness
enough money enough money to get by okay
and because i mean i know quite a few
very wealthy people and often they're
not the happiest people in the world
once you get to the top of something
you've got to keep yourself there's a
lot of pressure on and so on so yeah you
know you want to be comfortable but i i
i think it's a it's a false god to kind
of go i want to be a multi-millionaire
or or whatever yeah for me it's far more
interesting to have a good life in that
in that sense how how do you define a
good life
an interesting life one way you get up
in the bed in the morning and and you
think yeah i'm actually interested in
what i'm doing
today or you've got people around you
that share your viewpoint and you can
work with them and that you're doing
some good in the world hey friends thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day